it's too hard you gotta go to the office
she's expelled
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys today we have Mr Tim
Chan's boo earns Burns I feel like um so
so so uh talk we were talking about
tattoos in an earlier video right which
brought me to this like
kind of like realization about this new
generation so um I feel like what's new
generation of gen Z like the generation
now so the people in high school college
everything right like right yeah I think
so I would say gen Z yeah but then
what it seems like is like when we were
their age High School College there was
a lot of uh control still of the old
world traditions of like like let's say
conservative thought whatever you're in
right and then they control the way you
dress yeah the way that if you want
tattoos maybe it's like America's
becoming more modern or like um Asian
America is becoming more modern right so
like our parents generation
um they were more strict
but then let's say the Gen Z's parents
are younger than them so they accept
like oh yeah fashion or like they were
younger when they were in America they
might even be second generation so they
get like the U.S fashion makes sense to
them they might even dress better
whereas our parents would be like they
wouldn't get the fashion so they would
just write it off as like that's
gangster or like don't wear that [ __ ]
right so then what I'm witnessing now is
like
younger kids are allowed to dress better
than when we were growing up better in
what way it's like encouraged there they
could dress with the times okay and even
their options too so like let's say you
go to like Target back then it was like
really bad if you know the difference of
mall clothes and like Kmart clothes yeah
but like now it's like everything is
like oh you can get away with going to
Ross and [ __ ] or whatever like you could
just wear normal [ __ ] right where back
then it was like you're either a [ __ ]
nerd because you dressed this way
or your parents dressed you or you could
like go out and like look a certain way
same with like tattoos and stuff you see
everybody with tattoos now right and
people aren't like being controlled as
frequently as we were there was way more
social shame in like how you look I get
you I think there's definitely not
because of the internet right and
because you have so many more opinions
that maybe you weren't exposed to before
and so many people being like yo how you
gonna tell me about this when you know
about this that like people are kind of
forced to be more open-minded or else
they're like being like discriminatory
like in the sense of like you know back
then when we were growing up let's say
like somebody had the hair like in locks
right like back then it was like you
could never have a quote-unquote
professional job and have dreadlocks
right yeah now it's like you can't tell
somebody how to do their [ __ ] hair or
it's like yo this is kind of this feels
discriminatory you know what I'm saying
now because of internet and because so
many people have these conversations
it's like okay look have whatever the
[ __ ] hair you want I can't call this
professional or not because oh that's
kind of right it feels kind of racist
right yeah but we grew up during a time
when there was a lot of white
assimilation too that you had to do
because if it's like they don't care if
it's your culture they're just like
that's not the standard haircut for a
company yeah and then there would be
that but there's also other religious
things that they would impose on you
like for example the the school that we
went to I got kicked out for my haircut
they said that's not Christian like
because you had the A's the anti-asian
banks yes yeah yeah and I was like okay
so that's your reason it's probably
other reasons but that's the one that
they got that happened nowadays though
social media would be on the ass like oh
what kind of hair is not Christian like
right yeah yeah yeah I get you I get you
I mean even for me back then
uh when I first started wearing baggy
pants and [ __ ] you know my dad was like
why are you trying to guess like a dress
like a gang member and luckily for me my
parents were real open-minded about [ __ ]
you know like he I was like that this
isn't I'm not trying to be a gang member
I'm just [ __ ] like I'm just I'm just
cool dad you know what I'm saying and
eventually he let me be like oh God
we're going to the mall you got me a
whole a Sean John Jean suit oh that's
cool thank you it was it was it was one
Christmas but I was like all right just
get a bunch of outfits whatever you want
I got a [ __ ] Sean John denim suit
damn that's pretty hardcore that is
Hardcore I got a whole [ __ ] um
academics jumpsuit oh that was high
school this is I'm still like in eighth
grade but he let me get the dip eighth
grade you had Sean John soon yeah bro
one [ __ ] shiny Sean John suit one
baby blue sweat suit
yeah
a ludicrous music video
with a matching with Snapback oh of
course no then in high schools when I
was like you know I got the academics
sweat suit and [ __ ] but I was like
buying my own [ __ ] at this point so he
couldn't really say anything to me you
know but um but yeah I think luckily for
me I was uh I was lucky enough to have
parents that were like all right all
right fine they knew I wasn't in a
[ __ ] gang they're like all right fine
wear your baggy pants pull your pants up
whatever you know what I'm saying but it
was it was a struggle but yes I I hear
what you're saying when you when you
bring that up are you saying that it's
crazy that things are more relaxed now
or is it like they don't know the
struggles that we went through like
what's the juxtaposing Thought are you
bringing what's your point
the observation that I'm making right is
that do you guys see that is that now
they don't have the same so I think I
mean you're kind of like low-key talking
about just the Asian American Experience
right like to go from first gen to
second gen is already like such an
exponential difference you know what I
mean so for our parents to come here and
not just like assimilate to new fashion
but just like assimilate to like new
language or or customs in general
fashion is probably the [ __ ] bottom
of their list of totem pole [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying and now suddenly
it's like you have to be Keen to it
because we're the ones that are already
adults and we're talking about like you
know our own children or whatever of
course it's going to be lacks and open
mind because that was [ __ ] that we cared
about at our youth yeah is all so now
caring about it it's just a higher
Echelon and we have other different
worries you know especially being our
minority culture which is huge because I
feel like uh the Asian American
Experience hasn't been properly uh
documented because we're still living it
I'm not saying anybody's done a bad job
right yeah I'm just saying like we're
still living in it so like all this
Evolution that you're even talking about
like maturation and seeing [ __ ] like
that that's like tip of the iceberg
every [ __ ] category every industry
like that is the exact same thing
loosison food culture dating culture
[ __ ] online whatever the [ __ ] like
same [ __ ] fashion is clear though what's
the Counter Culture way of dressing
today because you know back in the day
you had people that dress like gangsters
and you know people are just like punks
and those were the Counter Culture looks
that you were like oh stay away from
those guys but like what's today's look
of like everything's commercialized
that's the thing I don't feel like there
is that anymore because of what he was
talking about yeah I feel like that's
gone I think everything is very
commercialized yeah so there's no like
underground culture there's no like like
like for for example tattoos right it
meant something when you had a tattoo
back then like it really meant that
you're a part of an underground
organization or you're a punk or like
you were not a part of society yeah and
you couldn't get a job you were just
discriminated against but then now
dude if you have a tattoo you work at
Starbucks you could do whatever you
could be an officer it doesn't matter
you got [ __ ] blue hair you don't need
a dye your hair to look like you know
for a job in the professional anymore
like they're like okay this is your
individualism I can't say [ __ ] to you or
I'm gonna get into some [ __ ] yeah cool
also fashion back then is like if you
look poor it's because like you were
poor
nowadays it's like you're kind of you
got like Yeezy stuff coming out of
[ __ ] garbage cans or like uh
Balenciaga stuff looking like derelict
now you know what I'm saying um that
that's a part of the county culture
right like choosing to report even
though it's like a thousand dollars for
those [ __ ] torn up but also if you're
wearing Yeezy and Balenciaga you're
saying I hate I hate Jewish people and I
like pedophiles Counter Culture baby
that's true it's the modern day Counter
Culture like maybe because there isn't
that in fashion as much because
everything is through like social media
and internet can be spread so quickly
now that it's like as soon as something
is its own underground it's boom
mainstream do you think maybe that's why
like people identify so hard with
political groups and like movements and
[ __ ] because I don't I remember growing
up it was like oh you feel that way you
feel that way that's cool whatever but
now it's like yeah I don't really give a
[ __ ] but not feel that people are like
fighting to the end it's their
personality yeah that's what they it's
fashionable for for young people like
because when we were in high school and
in college people were like oh you're in
activism like dude you angry for what
yeah I got a life bro I mean even if you
watch like
um 21 Jump Street right
um and it was the difference between
them going back to high school and like
Channing Tatum's character being like ah
no I'm gonna kill it in high school
because I was like a jock back then I
was cool right and he went back and he
said something and they're like they're
like uh dude what what where is this
coming from uh like and all the Nerds
were the cool ones because they were
more intelligent [ __ ] yeah and he was so
confused what's in that V8 yeah
yeah so that was like that was kind of
true I was like oh shit's different now
you know because I think it's also
worldwide too where like um the parents
of gen Z now like even if they are
immigrants or whatever like they're not
as hard-headed as their parents right so
like you see it all over the world where
like people are dressing much better
less conservative or like they have more
fashion or whatever it is and they don't
see it as they don't put the meaning
behind it as like if you dress like this
then you're a bad person right like that
used to be a thing that's what's
interesting to me is like when you watch
a 90s movie or a 2000s movie even and
you see a group and they're going like
this and it's like those are the bad
guys right oh we can't those are those
are the thugs like the bad people
there's no look for that no more yeah
the foot soldiers yeah you guys ever
seen Herald and Kumar too yeah bruh
there's one part where they [ __ ]
they're in this like really designer car
or this like sports car and they they
smash into a a fire hydrant in like a
bad neighborhood right so all like these
like you know aggressive looking black
dudes stop playing their basketball game
they come [ __ ] walking up with
crowbars and [ __ ] they're like yo like
the because the water from the Hydra
fire hydrant gets on it's like my Jays
whatever they walk up they're [ __ ]
with the Crowbar and Harry come on like
oh [ __ ] let's get the [ __ ] out of here
and then they're like yo one guy comes
up with a spare tire what the [ __ ] we
were trying to help you what happened
you're like what happened where'd they
go
yeah man that is you know like
I think about
um how uh how like uh when we were in
high school if a girl dressed a certain
way it might be like dang dude she kind
of like [ __ ] or like she you know when
she shows her thong like yeah just
showing a little bit whale tails but I
feel like the way that an average you
know what I mean the average youth will
dress now you're like damn that's edgy
as [ __ ] compared to what we were doing I
mean they just dressed like strippers
even look I went to a a Catholic High
School for one year right freshman year
and back then the rule was you can't
have your skirt rolled up to a certain
uh extent above you and it would measure
that was somebody walking around with
the [ __ ] measuring tape so I feel
like now if a school was to do that
they'd be like yo you're sexualizing
miners that's on you for being
disgusting right they can't you can't
kids got smart [ __ ] yeah she's different
now you know what I'm saying now it's
like oh if you're looking at a 14 year
old girl like she's nasty you the nasty
what why are you looking at that how you
gonna shame me like that right so it's
just completely different remember they
used to do like a finger like spaghetti
strap you don't like to go up to a chick
oh you need to go into pretty close
right yeah
teachers are like you're looking way too
[ __ ] sexy right now
oh oh
that's the test
the tanks we go ah oh damn go to the
principal's office damn
measure my dick my dick is too hard you
gotta go to the office
holy [ __ ]
measure your own dimmes someone measured
my dick this student has me hard she's
expelled a couple of years ago
um my niece graduated high school and
she went to this this private high
school that that was a part of our
religion right and then so um I remember
how strict it is was on on dress and
hair and everything and then so when I
was there it felt like I was out of
public school and I was just
mind-blowing because I never would have
thought that the religion would ease up
to that point really and let everybody
dress like more normal interesting so
I'll because back then there was a clear
distinction between like private school
Christian School kids and how they
dressed versus public school kids yeah
now I was like I was they're like what
the [ __ ] like this never would have
happened when we went to school right
like and the way that they could dress
like they you couldn't tell the
difference anymore so I was like dude
it's just different right like I was
like how how is this happening like
maybe everyone is just becoming more
like accepting or whatever even in the
festival scene it's crazy like when
we're going to Raves like people are
dressing more comfortable and then now
it's like everyone looks like they just
took Victoria's Secret clothes and just
put it on and you know why I think it's
because they're comfortable because
when you go to those festivals because
you know like I've been to a couple you
don't want to be that [ __ ] creep so
no one even looks really you know what
I'm saying they're invisible yeah so the
girl's like what you want look
at him am I invisible to you hey all
right the tits are down here buddy
stop looking at me in my eyes also also
you're on the love drug and that just
like takes the horniness out you know
what I mean
no no that's ecstasy different yeah
different I never had a boulder on
ecstasy no really
that's a lot but I see it on both ends I
see like chicks dressed in like almost
wearing nothing and then dudes that work
out they're just shirtless yeah yeah
yeah so it's almost as if they're both
on both sides are very like edgy and as
naked as possible yeah and you see a gay
guy with a thong and angel wings just
walking around and you can see that at
the Raves back then no you didn't see
any of that but yeah we pulled up the
pictures of you at Raves when you were
15 and everybody had massive pants big
ass shirts yeah pacifier Mickey Mouse
hands yeah we went through Mickey Mouse
hands visors and pacifiers that's the
one sweater
yeah sweaters big asses big ass big
sweaters yeah but that's how we looked
outside of race too sometimes
we look like idiots did you guys have to
wear uniforms at school yep not in the
high school I went to Oxford Academy at
one point from like seven to like eighth
grade where's that at uh Cyprus okay you
gotta test into that one huh yeah I had
to test into it at that time um and
there was something that I pre maybe
because my [ __ ] was [ __ ] poor and I
was wearing Payless all the time anyway
but there was something I appreciated
what everybody had to wear uniforms
because before outside of wearing
uniforms it's just like
somebody rolled to school with some
fresh [ __ ] and it's like their parents
bought that for them and it's like
that's how style got judged you know
what I mean it's like oh man my parents
can afford this so they took me to TJ
Maxx in Burlington Coat Factory you know
what I mean I had what I worked with but
whenever they had wear uniforms that
didn't turn into how are you going to
style your own [ __ ] everybody kind of
has to work off the same foundation and
your kicks yeah and then you learned
about a little bit more fashion and
style and choices versus what you're
limited to it's like everybody getting
the same [ __ ] playpen and then
working around versus just everybody
getting toys for Christmas so you didn't
you know what it sounds like a broke boy
to me you know what I'm saying
you guys had a laundromat right you
should have stole some clothes yeah I
bet you got some good friends from there
I mean I [ __ ] you know took some
stuff but the things that were left in
laundromat [ __ ] with people like I
didn't get [ __ ] tie clips [ __ ]
like cufflinks someone's bell bottoms
[ __ ] one sock you have a drawer full
of left socks it is nice to not have to
compete with other people clothing wise
but then in my high school we didn't
have to wear uniforms and it was just
like this that the first month everybody
would come super hard with like cool Ash
clothes and then you just stopped giving
a [ __ ] yeah like everyone just gets too
tired repeating their [ __ ] oh and you
just go all right cool bro I had one
pair of Air Forces that I I painted like
custom player yellow and blue to match
this like
um this [ __ ] Warriors jersey I had
but because it was like that one pair of
shoes I was always I I was just buying
Mad Warrior [ __ ] to master shoes I had
like a Jersey a T-shirt and I would have
it on rotation like every two weeks it
looks like game day all the time
so I was just always buying yellow and
blue [ __ ] to match the shoes you know
yeah that that's real that's when the
real [ __ ] matters I did that with my one
pair of Filas that were like blue white
and red and luckily that went with
everything Tommy so it was like oh thank
God
damn those 90s Brads man that's crazy I
know and that [ __ ] was hard to get like
it was so expensive and then you think
about it you wore a lot of fake [ __ ] too
back then because people didn't care as
much back then bro when my family came
back from Thailand your boy was Decked
Out Burberry jacket
oh [ __ ] Lacoste shirts damn well my
parents went to China Town but was
[ __ ] USA oh yeah you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah you know what
I'm talking about you [ __ ] Chinese
[ __ ] ching chong hey dude come
on don't call me a ching chong
it's crazy
that's a little too much I think I like
the ones where it's obviously wrong like
ideas
that was a big one that was like the
swappy one the Slauson Swami hat ideas
yeah it was like a soccer ball instead
of the last a that's not I'm bad now I
want to go out and just look for those
clothes so I could like wear it ideas
you can still find it old school I used
to remember like I don't know if y'all
remember FUBU Platinum The Fat Albert
[ __ ] was super popping when I was in
high school but it was so expensive so I
would get all my [ __ ] from the swapping
right but there was one Asian dude in
school this guy named Paris he had
parents like the most in Paris he had
the most gear he had these [ __ ] Fat
Albert food Platinum jeans within and
said hey hey hey on the back pocket and
he had these matching Nikes I was like
oh he was so [ __ ] flat-headed Tupac
nose ring he was in high school oh this
[ __ ] was so fly bro he had a
little Latina girlfriend with big ass
titties he was cool
where are you now
Paris where are you now oh what happened
to him oh he's homeless oh for real no I
like that that's something that can like
you can keep track that he's holding it
yeah
homeless is in you know his Facebook
status is still homeless
what did happen to the people with the
prettiest clothes in school though
that's interesting I want to know
because in in my experience people with
the coolest [ __ ] didn't end up staying
that cool like they stopped giving a
[ __ ] A lot of people do peek early yeah
like I like I remember looking up maybe
when I was in college the hottest chick
I remember in uh junior high her name
was Sally and it was like unanimously if
you like went around the whole school
and you voted everyone like oh Sally's
the hottest that is so cool and then in
in college I was like
and then I looked her I'm like what the
[ __ ] Sally you're [ __ ] up dude I'm
like damn what the [ __ ] happened to you
that's Bart's data set for the entire
nation I'm like you peaked so [ __ ]
early dude not gonna happen not gonna
lie guys but for how old we are we look
pretty awesome you know what I'm saying
everyone I'm 25 how old are you yeah 24
and a half but I'm just saying like a
lot of people we went to high school
with man it's not looking too hot I
think I'm about to peek in my 60s yeah
yeah I'm about to pick up what are you
at what are you at right now I'm 38. oh
[ __ ] halfway there so you got a long way
to go oh you're good bro I think we all
look predictively better than we thought
we would you know like when you were in
high school you probably saw yourself at
like late 30s looking like an old ass
dude I thought I was gonna like just
because based off your own parents right
yeah I thought like when I started when
I'm 30 I'm tucking all my shirts in
yeah I just thought like that's what you
do you're an old man I didn't even think
past 20s I thought I was gonna die like
Tupac
oh [ __ ] I'm glad you're here man that
makes sense for you though yeah that
does make sense for you like that's how
Joe would think about his life as he got
older yeah I didn't think well Adam 30
was even a word do you regret being
alive 30 wasn't even a word what are we
talking about it doesn't even exist in
my vocabulary because the maximum
capacity for life is 20 something well
because 30 sounded like oh once you're
30 like you don't have any more fun like
mine I was like oh 30s like you just
work were you able to imagine past 20
something I honestly was I didn't even
know what happened right no you would
look at 20 people 20 some people you'd
be like you're old right especially this
because I used to love watching the real
world and then to to submit for the real
world you had to be between 18 and 25.
so I used to think like past 25 your
oldest [ __ ] you're washed nothing else
happened yeah that's what I thought if
you were too old for MTV like what the
[ __ ] like you're just an old old man at
that point yeah
I really thought that after college and
you're done that nothing new happened
whatever you're doing after college
that's what you do till you die I was
like oh all right I thought you were 50
and you buy like a yellow Corvette or
something yeah
let your falling ass head Blow In The
Wind there's a lot of people like Al
Bundy was our hero ah four touchdowns in
one game I mean
women's shoe salesman
to me 30 to 50 seem like the same [ __ ] I
just like throw away and then 50 and on
it was a senior citizen yeah yeah then
you're cool again
[Music]